foreign
[Music]
for Wednesday January 11th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
the state of New York plans a major
shift to boost the number of electric
vehicles on its roads ears Governor
Kathy hokel at the New York
International Auto Show last year
finally we stopped this war between our
vehicle transportation and an assault on
the environment with leaning hard into
electric vehicles and that is why by the
year 2035
100 of new vehicles sold in the state of
New York will be zero emissions we are
leading the nation my friends and it's
starting right here in the state of New
York and I'm very very proud of that New
York's plan to ban gas vehicles follows
a precedent set by California to do the
same with the aim of cutting greenhouse
gas emissions but one particular
challenge for New York will be drivers
in New York City where many people rely
on street parking and there aren't all
that many places to put charging ports
with me to talk about this is wsj energy
reporter Jennifer Hiller hi Jennifer
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me I want to just start by laying out
the scale of this challenge I mean can
you tell us how many drivers now in New
York City have electric cars and how
many places are there to actually charge
them so fewer than one percent of
drivers in New York City have EVS it's
you know 20 something thousand drivers
so it's a small share of the drivers
that are out there and there's also not
a lot of charging locations at this
point there's about 1300 pieces of
equipment out there that would be
available to all kinds of EV drivers to
public charge over a period of several
hours and then there's about 74 fast
Chargers and that's coming from State
data and from the Department of energy
which tracks EV Chargers and from a
atlas public policy which is an EV data
company
okay so they're going to need a lot more
Chargers to meet this you know change
that New York is hoping to get when it
stops allowing the sale of new gas
powered vehicles and Jennifer full
disclosure I lived in New York City I
had a car when I lived in New York City
which I had to park on the street as
most people there do it's hard to
imagine where I would have charged it if
it was electric where are they planning
on putting these chargers right the city
estimates they have an enormous need for
public Chargers just because of the
thing that you mentioned most people in
New York are parking on the street they
don't have dedicated garage spaces where
they can leave their cars overnight and
so in New York probably more so than any
other city in the U.S by far you need a
lot of public Chargers available to
people and so those are going to be in
parking garages and you're also going to
have them essentially out on the street
they're looking at doing a lot of
curbside charging in neighborhoods and
the idea being that if they put enough
carbside Chargers out there that people
will be able to find a place to plug in
during the day or overnight but it is an
enormous infrastructure build out that
they are talking about doing the city
thinks it needs about 40
000 slower Chargers which are the kind
that maybe you plug in over a period of
you know six eight hours or more and
they want about 6 000 fast Chargers so
that is just a far cry from what exists
right now in the city you know Jennifer
real estate in New York is so expensive
how do they plan to get the space to
install these Chargers yeah that's one
of the big challenges for people who are
developing these sites you know real
estate is costly inexpensive and in New
York is not an easy City to build in or
to add any kind of infrastructure so the
permitting process can be complicated
you have to go through a process with
the utility as well and that can be
complicated hated and so you know New
York is an expensive place to add this
kind of equipment there is a lot of
State money on the table there's a lot
of federal money on the table that can
help offset some of the cost of
installing this kind of equipment but it
is not by any stretch of the imagination
and easy thing for people to build right
now it takes a lot of electricity
industry expertise and it also takes a
lot of real estate industry expertise to
get a project like this done I think
especially on the fast Chargers which
require quite a lot of power you know a
large fast charging site can draw as
much power as a skyscraper so it's not
just adding a few pieces of equipment
and plugging them into the existing
system and you're done you're talking
about utility upgrades that need to
happen as well right where is all that
extra power going to be coming from so
some companies are essentially drawing
it from the buildings that are already
there because the power system for the
building exists and depending on you
know how you manage the charging and you
manage the power use of the building
there might be enough power there
already otherwise you know it's coming
from the grid and so that could be an
issue over the years as you start to add
more and more charges in New York or in
cities across the country that it's a
new use of electricity that we don't
have right now on that kind of scale you
know most experts seem to think that
with managed charging you will be fine
and that there is enough power there but
I guess time will tell and see if they
run into any hiccups and adding this
kind of equipment I imagine this isn't
just a New York problem won't other
cities face similar challenges when they
try to make a shift towards more UVS
yeah I think most of our you know large
cities in the US have dense Urban cores
but I do think New York is unique in
some ways I mean it is going to have far
more people that are going to to rely on
public charging than other cities in the
U.S and you're just talking about like
the kind of density that we really don't
have anywhere else in the country at
least not on this scale so it is unique
a little bit in that way it's hard to
find kind of a one-to-one comparison for
New York but at the same time the same
things that New York is dealing with are
the same issues that are going to play
out in other cities across the country
all right that's our energy reporter
Jennifer Hiller Jennifer thanks for
joining us thanks so much for having me
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing for more Tech stories check out
our website wsj.com
I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall Street
Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]
[Music]